all right welcome back Clark hey Mark I
haven't seen you in a while yeah man
it's been almost a year you have I think
a lot of my viewers favorite story ah
thanks bro yeah I mean the the responses
have just been amazing you know I I
still go on your site almost daily just
to check them check the comments yeah
yeah you know I figure if if people take
the time to leave a heartfelt message
then I'll respond to it so we'll get
somebody telling you you're lying like
every video
you know I couldn't believe that I could
pour my heart out to you and uh and
people would be like this is [__]
it's like it's every single video on my
channel I'm like so I respond back to
people and like what part of my story
don't you believe I mean you can Google
my story it's it's there and then they
don't respond back to me when I uh when
I ask them that yeah they disappear
quickly yeah
um you know one thing that that uh uh
irritated a few people was I I was
wearing chains in that first interview
you're wearing jeans now and I'm wearing
chains now so I just want I want the
people with sensory issues to see that
I'm taking my chains off I'm trying to
be considerate
so I don't want them to uh I didn't hear
anything but I think if you're listening
on headphones or whatever yeah yeah and
like it wasn't a lot of people but a few
people uh tweaked out
so uh
Let's uh very considerate of you take my
chains off I don't know where this clasp
is
oh and we're wasting valuables it was
probably the big one that was the
problem
all right there you go so there you go
everybody no more chains for uh the
interview excellent so what has been
going on in your life since you uh
well you know
there's uh you know there's Seasons to
life Mark uh
you know you're gonna have good and bad
you're going to have Summers and you're
going to have cold dark Winters and you
know just to to recite a quick synopsis
of my my first interview
uh you know I was molested and raped by
My Boy Scout leader and he was also a
lieutenant in the local sheriff's
department he was the big man around
town he was involved in every
organization under the sun he hid in
plain sight
and uh you know there's a million
reasons why a child keeps silent about
sexual abuse you know uh
you know the pain and the shame and the
torment and and you know
the person's respected will anybody
believe you he's a lieutenant he's he's
you know on the historical society and
the Autobahn society and he's a trail
angel on the Appalachian Trail handing
out Waters to hikers he's everything and
he's a lieutenant in the sheriff's
department and
you know
um and you just uh
you just don't want to relive that pain
you so you know one one out of ten
children that are sexually abused speak
up
the other nine of us keep quiet and I
kept quiet yeah that's that's the stats
and I lived in silence my whole life
until I encountered him in a deli with a
young boy by him side calling him the
same nickname he used to insist I call
him you were holding the same
um when that happened I was uh 46.
and he raped me at 12. you know and uh
you know as I detailed in the first
episode you know just you know my life
went down one dead end Street after
another and after encountering him
it opened up all my wounds I spiraled
out of control doing heroin cocaine
Around the Clock pain pills Xanax
bottles of vodka you name it any any
drug I could get
One Drug alone wasn't enough to to
squash the pain that got ripped open
and uh one night I I went to his house
to confront him and we got into a uh
bloody fight
um and at the end of it he laid dead you
know I I I was charged with first degree
murder I was facing life in prison
I did five years
um
and in that five years I turned my life
around and I'm going to go into that but
I ended your segment with all the
positive things that were happening you
know I I became an advocate in New
Jersey and I changed uh myself and the
other Advocates changed the statute of
limitations law
um you know I did a documentary with NBC
I was on the Tamron Hall daytime talk
show
uh I signed a multi-episode documentary
uh with a with a producer and I had just
gotten a book deal with Simon and
Schuster
and then I closed it out with
um
and on top of all that I finally reached
back out to my college sweetheart who
wanted to get married after we graduated
and because of all that crap I had
inside of me I couldn't commit to her
and I walked away and it haunted me for
30 years I reached out to her and we got
back together
that's how I ended
the first segment are all up to date
yeah so so you would think hey Clark's
you know life owes Clark things are
going to go great it's smooth sailing
yeah it doesn't work that way what's
happened you know uh life is always
going to punch you in the gut there's
always going to be seasons of good and
then cold dark winners of bad
and you know you need a foundation
in you to whether the storm when it
comes
and you know I never had a foundation
and and two weeks before I committed the
murder
I showed up at a friend's house
blasted out of my mind on cocaine like
acting crazy I just got in a fight with
somebody over money
and my friend who was a big party guy
with me he's like dude he goes you're
starting to worry me man he's like
you're really out of control
and I told him right then I said as long
as my mother's still alive I won't do
anything stupid
once she dies all bets are off
and then two weeks later I went and
committed murder and he showed up at the
jail and and he's like
you know he didn't want it he didn't
know if we were being recorded but he's
like
so what happened to that talk we had two
weeks ago at my house and I just I just
Shrugged I'm like it went flying out the
window bro you know because I had no
foundation in me Mark
and uh you know I was always in a a
pursuit of pleasure you know to to to
push that pain down I was a pleasure
Seeker
so
you know when when I I got locked up I
decided to take my life in a new
direction and you know I got new habits
and I worked out strong
and I start my day off getting win after
win after win you know I get up early
that's win number one I pray and give
thanks before my feet hit the ground win
number two
um I meditate every morning again when
number three I read inspirational stuff
either out of the Bible or other books
win number four I make videos in the
morning when number five I eat healthy
win number six so before I start my day
before I leave the house I got six seven
wins under my belt and that's what you
got to do you know to take your life in
a New Direction
and uh you know I I got healthy habits
I'm sober I just celebrated 11 years
sober last month
um
so I had this good foundation
and back in December you know I did
something to my shoulder working out and
I had to lower my weights lower my
weights lower my weights I was doing
almost no weight at all and it was still
killing me so I just I had to stop
lifting and and exercise you know it's a
key for my therapy you know I I need to
to work out
so I wasn't working out
my mental state wasn't the greatest and
in February
I I came home and I found my brother
dead on our kitchen floor
you know my older brother who I worked
with in in the tire automotive industry
for 16 years
um
and uh
you know
what happened Mark is when I got
arrested it opened up his Pandora's Box
and the animal who were molested me had
molested him as well and he
couldn't face that trauma he didn't want
to relive it he didn't want to go back
to it he didn't want to grow from it he
didn't want to heal from it
and
he was using all the steps I was doing
before I got arrested to push that pain
down
and I was living with him him and my
mother when I got out of prison I went
to live with my mother and my brother
was there my brother had lost his his
business while I was locked up he he
lost his 33 Acre Farm he got divorced
and uh you know it was tough to watch
and I kept trying to reach him and reach
him and reach him
and uh
you know nobody wants to hear from their
younger brother you know how they should
you know their younger brother who's the
motivational speaker you know how they
should turn their life around you know
so you know I I I I I you know I I I did
everything I could you know to try to
get him to uh turn his life around
and uh eventually he started going to
the gym you know I got him to go to the
gym it lasted a couple weeks and then he
started drinking heavily again
and then he went back after a couple
months and uh you know did it for a
little longer this time and then started
drinking again
and then the third time it caught and he
got sober for nine months he was doing
good you know but he didn't have that
Foundation under him like uh like you
know I said I had to build it myself and
without that Foundation you know he
started drinking again but he was still
going to the gym and uh
you know it's just a a combination of
ill health and and drinking
and uh you know I found him on our
kitchen floor dead
I had been at the gym right before I
came home and I said to the gym owner
was my brother in today he's like yeah
he was here he said he wasn't feeling
that good though I'm like huh and then I
get home and there he is dead on our
floor I gave him CPR paramedics came did
CPR and uh he was gone
and uh his death you know like
triggered
all my childhood memories I felt like
Dennis Pegg my abuser my brother's
abuser like from the grave snatched him
and uh
and you know and it set me into a
tailspin you know and I started
backsliding you know
um I couldn't I couldn't get the mental
strength to go to the gym uh
I
I started eating crappy
put on weight
I was taking care of my mother who's in
her 90s
and uh you know I'd come home every day
and I'd be like what'd you do Mom
I stared out the window and I went to
your brother's room and talked to him
for an hour
and this was day after day and
eventually my sister and I decided you
know my mother's health failed she was
in and out of the hospital multiple
times
and we got her into a retirement
community eventually and uh you know
uh once I got her settled in you know I
decided
you know I took a look at myself with
how I was living
and how I felt and I felt like crap
and I'm like I gotta uh I gotta
change things
you know I was getting up later right
before I had to go to work I'm getting
up you know and uh so now I started
setting my clock earlier I'm getting up
at 4 30. I started meditating again
I started you know reading the Bible
reading uh inspirational books I started
making videos for YouTube I started
eating healthy again just a clean
protein diet
and uh and then uh you know I'm 57 years
old and I started doing burpees again at
the gym I'm going nuts with burpees
every day to get rid of this the gut I I
got it's going down and uh you know
I had that Foundation
I knew I was backsliding
and I stopped myself before it backslid
any further you know where if you if you
don't put on the brakes where would it
have led me you know I see the videos of
the you know the people you know on skid
row and Kensington Avenue you know doing
drugs and uh
you know they don't have that Foundation
you know to put on the brakes to be like
how am I living and I looked at myself
how am I living I'm not happy with how
I'm living and I wasn't even doing drugs
you know I just wasn't eating healthy
and taking care of myself and I I had to
put on the brakes you know
um and I and I've turned things around
over the last three months you know and
uh
you know I want to talk about
four victims of of my abuser Dennis Pegg
for his victims
my my brother was six years older than
me and my next door neighbor was best
friends with my my brother we grew up in
a lake community and right across the
street
was Jeff's house
and Jeff and my brother were inseparable
and Jeff was always at our house and
Jeff had the basketball court on in his
driveway the basketball hoop and I was
always over there playing basketball so
all the three of us were always together
and my brother and Jeff were in the
scouts ahead of me
and at 23 years old Jeff put a shotgun
in his mouth and killed himself
and his death has haunted me my whole
life
and with him went whatever secrets from
Dennis Pegg abusing him to the Grave
you know the next so that's victim
number one I wanted to talk about victim
number two is Peg's own nephew after I
got arrested for his murder
Dennis Peg's nephew killed himself with
a shotgun and the prosecutor in court
said on Peg's computer they found
sexually provocative photos of the
nephew
so even Peg's own family members weren't
off limits to him
so two victims two gunshots two suicides
victim number three my brother
as I said my arrest opened up his
Pandora's Box
and my brother you know spiraled out of
control the last few years it was it was
tough to watch it was tough to witness I
tried to get him into therapy
I tried to get him to go to AAA
um
try to get them to get Faith
eventually I got him to you know go to
the gym you know and even on his last
day of life
uh he was at the gym you know and that
gives me some comfort that he hadn't
given up on himself but he was abusing
his body on a daily basis
and his body just gave out so victim
number three you know dead
so three victims three deaths and then
I'm victim number four
and uh you know I almost lost lost my
life uh on multiple occasions
uh I almost spent life in prison
you know and uh I have a I have a
friend's wife who works in law
enforcement who sat in on
um you know many uh
many investigations about Dennis Pegg
when when my case was going on
and she told me
after I got out of prison you know that
they estimate his victim count is well
over a hundred you know he was a Serial
pedophile
and uh you know he destroyed a lot of
lives
so I just want to I just want to say
life doesn't owe you anything
you know you would think all right
Clark's been through so much life's
going to be smooth sailing it doesn't
work that way and you have to have a
good foundation to weather the storms
you know so I can't stress enough to
people you know
start getting wins to start your your
day off
get healthy habits
self-improvement
eat healthy get Faith you know
the atheists in your audience boy did
they tear me apart
I if somebody comes to me and says Clark
strawberries changed my life I eat a
strawberry and I smile a strawberry
fills my insides with joy
have a strawberry like I'm not gonna sit
there and say you fool do you think that
little red berries like changing your
life you're
and yeah that's what I got from from
members of your audience the first go
around you know but that's what faith
did for me I was filled inside
with rage and anger and hatred and
self-loathing and violence and
destruction the first half of my life
was just destruction
and
you know victims of of sexual abuse not
only do they hate themselves because
they blame themselves for the abuse
but then they live a self-destructive
life and that just heaps more
self-hatred on top of self-hatred
and uh you know
so I'm filled with this self-loathing
and self-hatred
and I needed to let love and light back
into my being and Faith did that you
know I'm not talking religion I'm
talking faith in a higher power and you
know I became a born-again Christian yes
you know so my faith is in Jesus uh and
that changed my life you know and
if you if strawberries change your life
have at it brother you know that's you
know but man I got tore apart you know
by the non-believers you know and that
and that's what uh you know that's when
I make a post or something and I talk
about faith uh Faith to me equals love
and I needed to let love back into my
heart and to my being and Faith did that
so you know get wins to start your day
get new habits get self-improvement get
Faith eat healthy and get sober you know
like I I mentioned at the start I just
celebrated 11 years sober when I was
using drugs and alcohol I didn't
Envision life without them you know the
the arresting officer of the State
Police you know who told me to keep my
mouth shut going into the interrogation
room you know like he's like do not say
a word in there
um he said to me did you have an exit
strategy when you were using all those
drugs I'm like nah bro there's no exit
strategy you're just riding that wave
for as long as you can until it crashes
and my wave you know totally crashed
you know so uh you got to get sober too
if you want to heal you were using when
you murdered Dennis yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know you have
done it if you were sober no that's you
know that people ask me that you know do
you regret murdering Dennis oh
that's a tough one you know
because it should never have come to
that no you know he should have been he
had over a 40-year reign of terror like
I said over a hundred kids
they estimate six suicides five six
suicides to him maybe a lot more
all right let's let's now that you
brought that up
um a lot of responses from your audience
where you did exactly what I want to do
sure all right listen if you do what I
did killing Dennis Pegg all right
I wiped an animal off the face of the
Earth he was
people who go he spent his life hunting
children
to me that's not a a person with
Humanity I don't think there's a single
victim he had whose life wasn't
destroyed by it right
so to me he lost his Humanity a long
time ago
so I I you know it doesn't keep me up at
night for what I did shouldn't but it
didn't heal me
and that's the thing like yes I I
destroyed a pedophile predator but in
the way it just added you know all sorts
of crap that I had to heal from you know
so and people that reach out to me that
say you know I did what they want to do
you know I can't stress enough you know
you have guys on all the time that have
been in prison you know I can't stress
enough you don't want to go to prison
you don't want to spend your life in
prison for getting revenge against your
abuser
it's simply not worth it prison is hell
you know you're dealing
I don't care I don't care how bad you
think you are how tough you are when you
get to prison it's it's all bets are off
you know and uh to me what's most
impressive about your story is not that
you you murdered your
uh your you know what do you call them
my monster your monster yeah
um that's how it's most impressive
what's the most impressive is how you
put your life back together that's it
and that's the story you know so your
girl is beautiful your life looks you
look healthy as can be
yeah yeah happy and healthy you know and
and you know so so killing your abuser
does doesn't solve your problems it
won't it won't fix your life you gotta
you still gotta address your pain you
gotta heal from it you know and that's
what I did killing Dennis Pegg didn't
solve my problems it it got rid of a a
predator from hurting any other children
yeah that's great that's what it did but
it didn't it didn't fix me and I still
had to address me and as you just said
you know that that's the story you know
people call me a hero and I'm not a hero
for killing a pedophile
it's here it's heroic when somebody can
turn their life around yeah and that's
what I was able to do that's exactly
right yeah and and that's the story you
know so uh
you know I don't want people
what I want them to take away from my
story is all the mistakes I made in the
missteps don't follow my path
start healing now you know I just
outlaid
you know for people how to how to take
their life in a New Direction you know
get up early you know
start working out every day uh you know
get healthy habits and get sober and get
God
and uh that's what I did and uh it's
changed my life you know so so I went
through that dark period
and as I said you know Seasons come and
Seasons go I just got contacted by the
producer of the documentary I filmed
that the final edit is almost done
so that's going to be ready soon I just
saw the first 40 pages edited of the the
book I have going with Simon Schuster
it's an amazing first 40 pages
and uh we're gonna close it out the same
way I closed it last time talking about
my college sweetheart this weekend you
know I my brother died
I put my mother into a retirement
community I gutted the house we lived in
got it all fixed up it went on the
market this week and this weekend I'm
moving in with my girlfriend in New York
good for you you know so she came to me
a few months ago
and we met 37 years ago
and she said hey it's it's been 37 years
do you think we can finally live
together and I'm like why are you always
rushing me into things you know
so
so to close it out I'm moving in with my
girlfriend this weekend so a new season
starting uh you know things are coming
together congratulations one other thing
you know
I want I this was a point I wanted to
make also I'm at my brother's funeral we
did My Brother's funeral and we were at
a nice restaurant for his repass
and my phone dings
and
so I I check it and it's an email from a
girl from the New Jersey State Police
asking if I would be their keynote
speaker at their conference this year
and I'm like man of all the days to get
this uplifting news so I I responded I'm
at my brother's funeral I'll contact you
next week and she said so sorry I
contact her you know the next the
following week
and uh you know she said you know uh
we're we're having the crime lab Lab uh
has an annual conference for all the
members of the crime lab and the higher
higher-ups in the state police and uh we
would love for you to be our guest
speaker and I said fine and she's sent
me the date now I didn't pay any
attention to the date you know I'm I'm
dealing with my brother's death and my
mother's health and her in the hospital
the date turned out to be June the 12th
when I was going to speak to the state
police
that or sorry June the 13th that's the
day my house was surrounded by them and
I was arrested so 11 years to today that
I was arrested their guns are drawn
they're ordering me out over a bullhorn
out of my house
I go out I'm spread eagle on my front
lawn 11 years later
I'm now speaking hosting their
conference
and it was going on I S I spoke from 10
till 12 30 and they arrested me at 12.
so I was speaking to them at the time
they arrested me
uh you know you just you never know
where your life will head you know like
for them to reach out to me on my
brother's day we buried him you know it
was uplifting
and uh it was almost like God said look
you know I know you're going through a
tough time here's here's a you know
here's something to get you out of this
pull you through and uh and then to
speak to speak to them you know 11 years
to today was simply amazing you know so
your life has so many ironic twists yeah
I never envisioned you know I never
envisioned that happening you know so
people who are struggling people who
were
depressed and suicidal and addicted and
in prison I was in prison facing life in
prison for murder
and then I'm hosting the state police
conference you know it's crazy man so
just hang in there people you never know
where life is going to take you you know
just it's not gonna happen overnight but
it's gonna happen thanks Mark
glad to be back bro peace thank you
Clark